[Music]
the 30-day
declutter is at the
the core of my philosophy of digital
minimalism so this was
my take on what do we do about the fact
that starting around 2016
people became very uneasy about their
phones in a way that they weren't in
2014 there was this flip that switched
where at some point we realized
i'm looking at this thing too much like
this is a problem we got we got uneasy
and i could tell very precisely where
that happened just based on reactions to
my own work when it switched from you're
crazy you're crazy you're crazy you're
crazy you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right it happened in like a
very
quick period where my social media
skepticism in particular
really switched and so
my approach to it was
you can't start with the habits and the
tactics right you can't start with like
let me get right to
setting filters and turning off
notifications and not having my phone in
my bedroom and putting my my phone into
grayscale and moving my icons onto the
back screen on my iphone
that doesn't work you're going to end up
back where you were
and so
digital minimalism by contrast was this
humanist philosophy where it says no you
got to figure out what you're all about
like what you really care about and what
you want to do
and then work backwards and say what
text supports that
and that's how you choose
what tech you use in your personal life
and what rules you put around that you
start with what's important to me and
then you put the tech to work that's
much more sustainable
but how do you figure out this question
like how do you get that insight into
what do i really want to do what's
important to me when you already have
all that distraction that's where the
declutter came in and so i said take 30
days where you don't use social media
you don't stream
online videos the only podcast you
listen to is tim and minds and everyone
else you stop listening to no video
games no online news that's very
influenced by you and your low
information diet for example
and you experiment and you reflect and
you think about life and go for walks
and join things and ride your bike and
hang out with friends without you know
sending them messages on a glowing
bitmap screen and you figure out what
you're all about and then at the end of
the 30 days
you say what do i want to do and so i
had that idea
i mentioned it to my newsletter because
i was working on this book but i was in
the early days
and i said does anyone want to try this
and my thought was this is a big ask so
maybe seven people would say yes and my
plan was that's great i will follow
these seven people
and see how it goes and write like
pretty long profiles of them it'll be
good for the book
sixteen hundred people came back and
said yeah i'm doing it wow so i get
through that idea that i was gonna
follow everyone uh sixteen hundred
people did it
one of the people who was doing it was
the roommate of a new york times
reporter so then the new york times was
covering the declutter like it became a
whole thing
and then they i got hundreds and
hundreds of reports back from people
about their experience and what worked
and what did it but the main takeaway
was
it is much more effective if you want to
tame the
technology in your personal life if you
want to tame that if you're working
backwards from first principles of this
is what i want to do with my life how
can tech help it's incredibly
sustainable if you instead say i'm
unhappy with all the tech i'm using now
so let me try to put in rules to use it
less that's incredibly non-sustainable
you're almost certainly going to go back
to where you were before
so if people want to
give this a shot what should they do
well i mean beyond the obvious of buying
the the book i ended up writing
obviously yeah and a copy for each of
your friends because it's easier for
them to read it than you to have to
explain it once you've done that
it's actually straightforward
so literally what i say is just i call
them optional
personal technologies and i want to draw
a really clear line here this is really
about your personal life i've written
other books about email and slack and
technology in the working world that's a
whole other issue and it seems similar
but
there's different issues underlying it
so therefore different solutions but i'm
talking about
the stuff you do outside of work that
largely speaking has you looking at your
phone
you take a break from them from 30 days
if it's a dual use technology like i i
mainly use this for personal reasons but
there's some reason i need to use it
then you put up fences right so if
you're like i don't want a text message
but my daughter uses text messaging to
tell me when she needs to be picked up
from practice you put up a fence and say
well i'll still do that but i'm not
going to participate in text change with
my friends for the 30 days so you can
you can set the rules how you want to
set the rules
and then the only key thing is you go
through 30 days
be very active so in that experiment the
people who treated this like a detox
and i hate the application of that term
the technology i think it's a complete
misappropriation of that term people who
try to just white knuckle it and say yes
i'm just not going to use these
technologies for 30 days and just by not
using them something positive will
happen they never made it 30 days
but the people who are like i will now
be very aggressive about
reflection and experimentation trying
new things going places going to the
library buying a bike joining a running
club you know reading books going on
long walks
they're the ones who really kept with it
and at the end of the 30 days you
literally write out a code
here is the tech i use and the rules by
which i use it you know i'm going to use
instagram because i'm an artist
but the only way i'm going to use it is
on my computer the only people i'm going
to follow are these 10 artists that
really inspire me and i have a glass of
wine and look at their latest post on
friday evening and it's the only
interaction i have with that service
right so you get specific i'm using this
for this reason here's how i use it and
then you're you've reset you've married
condo'd your digital closet you took
everything out you only put back in the
stuff you cared about and uh and you go
for it
wine on friday for an instagram scroll
through 10 inspiring artists does sound
like it would spark joy
so thank you riconda
she's the tiniest woman
i've maybe ever met in my life she was
on the podcast 100 years ago i actually
interviewed her in japan and
she's the most
perfect
porcelain
skin i've ever seen on any human
really really uh may in fact be an alien
very sweet a very organized alien though
so
she's very organized alien be really
discouraging if this hyper advanced
alien civilization showed up and were
really really [ __ ] disorganized just
couldn't figure things out you'd be like
oh no
we thought we had so much clarity to
look forward to
and
it sounds like from your description
that the people who approach this type
of digital
minimalism experiment as one of
subtraction and that's their focus
they fail and those who view it as an
experiment with
new additions or substitutes to kind of
crowd out default
tech behaviors
are the ones who end up benefiting most
is that a fair
description
yeah we're good at humans to committing
the things that are positive like that's
very motivating for us
we're bad at trying to avoid things that
are negative right so it's very bad for
us to be like uh i think i use instagram
too much
i'm gonna try to use it less is like
that isn't very compatible with our
wiring but on the other hand like i have
this vision of my life that it's really
positive and it makes me feel good i'm
really into it oh and by the way that's
the vision in which i don't use
instagram is way more effective
you